Haití necesita ayuda internacional así
lo afirmó él en Lalín la enviada de
Naciones Unidas para el país caribeño
quien reiteró que sin las fuerzas
internacionales la policía local no
podrá hacerle frente a la violencia de
pandillera la cual dejó 2.183 asesinatos
en 2022 y una
saben que la situación en Haití es grave
saben que la violencia impulsada por
pandillas ha alcanzado nuevas alturas en
promedio enfrentamos un secuestro cada
seis horas en 2022
Necesitan ayuda la situación necesita
apoyo
la gente de Haití está sufriendo mucho
el pedido de Lalín refresca el realizado
por el secretario general Antonio
Gutiérrez en octubre pasado y sucede Un
día después de que Estados Unidos y
China propusieran incrementar las
sanciones contra los responsables de la
violencia urbana sin embargo la enviada
especial en Haití considera necesario un
esfuerzo mayor
podríamos actuar con más urgencia creo
que la comunidad internacional debe
hacerlo sin embargo se está considerando
activamente en este momento se discutió
en el Consejo de Seguridad y se está
discutiendo en la celac
no estamos haciendo lo suficiente para
poder ganar esta pelea en esta etapa ni
lo haremos sin niveles significativos de
apoyo adicional
el asesinato del presidente en 2021
agudizó una ola de diversas crisis en el
empobrecido país las pandillas
propiciaron bloqueos que generaron
crisis alimentarias y desabastecimiento
en tanto que también han surgido brotes
de cólera un contexto que lleva a miles
de haitianos a buscar la salida del país
[Música]